Oh pity team waa wycott Ottawa call
Marilyn tini
Chiara as you've heard when I was very
young I was elected to the New Zealand
Parliament and at that age you learn
mostly by listening to others stories I
remember a woman who'd been injured in a
farm accident and it was coming up to
sheering time on the farm and she had to
be replaced by a shepherd by a Rowsey in
the wool shed and of course there was
still someone needed to manage the
household and to prepare the food for
the shearing gangs and her mother came
to help with that but the family got no
compensation for the mother because
that's what mothers and family members
are supposed to do one year a company
called gold mines New Zealand applied
for a prospecting license on our
beautiful Mount padronia
it is a mountain full of extraordinary
ecosystems of Virdon Virdon native
forests it produced oxygen it was a
carbon sink it was a home for endangered
species and for pollinating species in
the farmland around and the mining
company put up this great economic
prospectus that was about how much money
could be made from mining our mountain
about all the growth and development
that would show in New Zealand's
budgetary forecasts and we were just
left with the language of all that we
valued about our mountain
fortunately we stopped and then I
remembered a woman who had three
children under five who was caring for
our elderly parents and nobody seemed to
think that at some stage she might
actually need some assistance with
childcare because she wasn't in the paid
workforce and they began to be a pattern
in all of these stories I was being told
and I started to ask enough questions to
try and track to the core of this
pattern of values that was part of all
of these stories and I found it in an
economic formula called the gross
domestic product or the GDP most of you
will have heard of it many of you won't
have any idea what it actually means the
rules were drawn up by Western educated
men in 1953 they established a boundary
of production in drawing up these rules
what they were keen to measure was
everything that involved a market
transaction so on one side of the
boundary everything where there was a
market exchange was counted it doesn't
matter whether the exchange is legal or
illegal market exchange and the illegal
trade in armaments musicians drugs
endangered species trafficking of people
all of this is great for growth and it
all counts on the other side of the
boundary of production there was this
extraordinary
rephrase in the rules that the work done
by the people they called non primary
producers was quote of little or no
value so I thought let's see how many
non primary producers we have here today
so in the last week or so how many of
you have transported members of your
household or their goods without payment
how many of you have done a bit of
cleaning a bit of vacuuming a bit of
sweeping a bit of tidying up the kitchen
yeah how about going shopping for
members of the household preparing food
cleaning up afterwards laundry ironing
well as far as economics is concerned
you were at leisure now how about the
women who have been pregnant and who
have had children yes now I really hate
to tell you this because it might well
have been hard labor but at that moment
you were unproductive and some of you
may have breastfed your infant now in
the New Zealand national accounts that's
what the figures are called
that's where we get the GDP in the New
Zealand national accounts the milk of
Buffalo goats sheep and cows is a value
but not human breast milk it is the very
best food on the planet it is the very
best investment that we can make in the
future health and education of their
child it doesn't count at all all of
those activities are on the wrong side
of the production boundary and something
that's very important to know about this
accounting framework they call it
accounts but there's no debit side we
just keep market exchanges going and
it's all good for growth we're in
Christchurch where people have lived
through a devastating natural disaster
and recovered and ever since that time
New Zealand has been told our growth
figures are great because we're
rebuilding Christchurch nothing was ever
lost from the national accounting
framework because of the loss of lives
the loss of land the loss of buildings
the loss of special
spaces now it might also be becoming
obvious to you that this boundary of
production works in terms of our
environment when we're mining it when
we're deforesting when we're deleting
our environment when we're fishing out
our marine resources legal or illegal as
long as market is exchanged it's all
good for growth to leave our natural
environment alone to sustain it to
protect it is apparently worth nothing
now how and what can we do about this
well I wrote first about it 30 years ago
then in 2008 after the global financial
crisis president Sarkozy of France as
three men who had all won Nobel prizes
and economics sin for to see and
Stieglitz to discover what I'd written
about 30 years ago
relying on per capita GDP relying on
these growth figures they said doesn't
appear to be the best way to proceed to
make public policy and I totally agree
with them one of the things that you
notice about these rules they are
revised 1968 they were revised 1993 2008
is that the revisions are mostly done by
statisticians and the statisticians do
know what is wrong with their data but
hardly any of the economists ever
stopped to ask that same question so in
2019 the GDP is an even worse shape you
see to measure GDP you have to assume
that some kind of production or service
delivery or consumption occurs inside a
nation-state and you know where that is
but trillions of dollars are circling
the globe in many parts from our
Google's our Facebook's our Twitter's
siphon through a number of tax shelters
so that when we click on our computer
and go to download some software we
don't know where it was produced and
frankly no one knows where we are as we
are consuming it either
these tax free havens distort the GDP to
such an extent that about three years
ago Europe looked askance at Ireland and
said we don't think you're reporting
correctly and then the next year their
GDP went up 35% now all that work that
you're doing when you were at leisure
and unproductive we can measure this and
we can measure this in time use surveys
when we look at the amount of time
that's taken in the
unpaid sector what we find is that in
almost every country where I've ever
seen the data it is the single largest
sector of the nation's economy in the
last three years for example the UK
statistician has declared that all of
that unpaid work is the equivalent of
all manufacturing and all retailing in
the UK in Australia the single largest
sector of Australia's economy is unpaid
childcare and the second largest sector
is all the rest of the unpaid work
before banking and insurance and
financial intermediation services clock
in at the largest part of the market
sector just last year the premier of the
victorious state of Australia declared
that half of that state GDP was in fact
the value of all the unpaid work now as
a policymaker you cannot make good
policy if the single largest sector of
your nation's economy is not visible you
can't presume to know where the needs
are you can't locate time poverty you
can't address the most critical issues
of need so what can go in the place of
GDP
well GDP has got many other problems
okay we don't behave in a way that
assists GDP large numbers of people
around the planet are now using
household assets because their homes
themselves for uber for air B&B and no
we're not supposed to use assets from
the unpaid sector to make money in the
market sector this is confusing
and very difficult to measure so
economists don't want to know what's
wrong with their most important GDP and
I think they've got so many problems
they can just move off to a quiet corner
and continue to publish that and not
come anywhere near the rest of us with
this talk of capitals and natural assets
and other ways in which to colonize the
rest of our lives I think time use is
the most important indicator going
forward every one of us has exactly the
same amount of it if there are going to
be critical issues as we move forward we
need a solid data base because whatever
we change away from the GDP we're going
to be stuck with it for about 50 years
and we need something that's solid and
immutable and that everybody understands
because if I put time use data in front
of you you'll immediately start nodding
you'll immediately start recognizing
what it means and honestly if I put the
GDP data in front of you a lot of you
would prefer to leave to for morning tea
we also need to be looking at the
quality of our environment as every year
goes past we get much better at
measuring the devastation of it of
measuring how little we protect anymore
and yet with climate change we don't all
have to be scientists to see to feel to
know what is happening to our beautiful
planet we need in this country the
Perriman sea of what we can learn from
kaitiakitanga from vernon Otunga from
what maori who have been here for
centuries can teach us when you're in
Parliament
and you're not in an Economist's frame
of mind you make decisions across a
range of data you look at the trade-offs
you think deeply about implications way
beyond whether or not GDP is up or down
economists want to turn everything into
a monetary exchange even time use data
so that they can carry on trying to
decide whether GDP is up or down that's
not a great way to go and others have
said to me Marilyn why don't you just
work on a system that includes all the
unpaid work and the pregnancy and the
birth and the lactation in the GDP
there's a very important moral and
ethical answer to that and it is that I
do not want the most valuable things on
earth the things I treasure sitting in
an accounting framework that thinks that
war is great for growth
[Applause]
[Music]
so from now on whenever you listen to
the news you're not going to go blank
when they say GDP you're going to think
I know what they're talking about and
it's not good I know that there are
alternatives and I'm going to spend my
time correcting people talking to them
about this value base and talking to
them about what the alternatives can be
because humankind and our planet need
another way thank you
[Applause]